[Music]
[Applause]
joining us now former NFL quarterback
babe lenberg Cowboys Radio color analyst
look at you you look great festive
background there big smile on your face
everything is great in Dallas right
right babe somebody told me Christmas is
coming up Dan uh it falls on the 25th
this year okay so I'm ready for it and I
would be remissed and if I did not say
hello from Kyle in California he's your
biggest fan he's my nephew he calls in
he's disappointed that he did not get
this slot but I said Kyle your day will
come when did things change for the
Cowboys offensively this year really at
the bye uh they went into the bye and I
don't want to say it's a a different
offense but it's almost a different
offense the the early incarnation of
what they call the Texas coast which by
the way I don't really like we have the
west coast and after that everything
else uh are just offenses but uh they
went into the buy I think they redid
things uh actually they look a lot more
like the offense that played last year
under Kell Moore they're taking
downfield shots they got Brandon Cooks
more involved in the offense uh which
was a big deal uh he has been very good
I don't know what happened to him in the
first six games and why they were not
using him uh he's obviously a veteran
established receiver but uh he's been on
fire as of late too so they now have a
lot of weapons and as you know Dak is
just playing outstanding how big is this
game for the Cowboys oh it's huge it's
huge well do you remember a regular
season game that was more important
recently with the Cowboys well there was
never been one that's been more
expensive Dan because on the secondary
Market the tickets are higher priced
than any regular season game in cowboys
history and I I kind of go back if you
go back to the early 90s if your
audience can remember remember back that
far uh the Cowboys could not get past
Philadelphia kind of late 80s 90s
Cowboys weren't real good unfortunately
I was a part of that Team 8 89 and 90
and you just couldn't get by
Philadelphia uh
1990 Troy got sacked 11 times and shut
out at home and it was like how do you
ever get by this team but ultimately
they did so this has a little bit of
that feel to it not quite as much
because obviously the Cowboys in Philly
recently I played a lot more close games
that team did but uh clearly if you want
to win the East if you want to get a
shot at HomeField you got to beat
Philadelphia Sunday night what are your
concerns personally or with the football
team with the football team because if
we're gon to talk about me then we're
gonna be here a
while uh you know the the the only thing
that is the concern for me is kind of
stopping the run if a team wants to get
in and really just Hammer the football
Cowboys play six defensive backs
basically on every snap so you're a
little bit Light in the Box there uh the
other part is they're they're much
better team on Turf they're 20 and one
on Turf since start of the 22 season
20-1 on Turf they're two- eight on grass
so it's a team that plays fast
defensively they have to play fast
because they're lighter uh even on the
interior they're a little lighter than
most teams so that's why to me getting
that HomeField Advantage if they can do
that is so Paramount because if you have
to go on the road to Philly Philly plays
on grass if you have to go on the road
to San Francisco San Francisco plays on
grass so to me that's a huge part of
this is the defense keeping up with the
offense now because earlier in the
season it was the other way around right
I mean Mike McCarthy coming into the
season basically wanted to said we got
to run the damn ball and we got to play
defense and that's the way he wanted to
win and then all of a sudden they said
wow this passing game is working pretty
well but uh defense has been playing
great obviously Seattle you probably saw
that game put up some points uh on this
defense but that was a heck of a game by
the way very exciting but Cowboys came
out on top but the Cowboys at home that
they're averaging 41 points I mean it's
ridiculous what they're doing at home
they have not lost at home since the
opener in the 2022 season to Tampa Bay
so they've been virtually unbeatable at
home where do you stand on the brotherly
shove play with the
Eagles uh here's my thing Dan the bear
defense was the rage nobody knew how to
block it we don't see the be defense
anymore right Wildcat came into Vogue
they said boy how are we going to defend
this thing nobody had an idea they'd
never seen it before you don't see the
Wildcat anymore So eventually somebody's
GNA figure out a way to stop that tush
push or quarterback sneak whatever you
want to call it but I I hey they're just
I don't want to say exploiting the rules
but the rule is in there that allows you
to do it and uh Philadelphia is clearly
uh the best at it everybody talks about
jayen hurs you know squatting 4,000 PBS
uh it's really not him it's Jason Kelce
it's the center he's the one that clears
things out but uh it's almost in a way
it's an ugly play but it's almost kind
of fun isn't it that you know fourth and
one you don't even think about what they
might do are they gonna go for it are
they gonna go to four wide receiver
personal it's like hey here here comes
the tush push as Jerry Jones ever
contacted you during a
broadcast no no no and it probably he
has better things I would hope he has
better things to
do but uh he actually has been very good
I don't think we've ever in my time this
my 27th year of of being the analyst on
the Cowboys Radio Network there hasn't
been a time when we have got a call in
the booth saying hey make it sound
better and I mean even during the week
uh of hey make it sound better you know
they went through three consecutive five
and 11 seasons and uh as you know Dan
honestly you you can't lie to your
audience they see the game you can't
make it if it's bad it's bad and when
it's good it's good and uh honestly we
we have had the Liberty to call the game
as we see it 27 years I've never had
that phone call Nick Bosa came out and
said the ners gave everybody the game
plan to stop Jaylen Herz it's nice when
you have the game plan but the game plan
also brings in the talent to be able to
carry out that game plan does Dallas
have the talent defensively to carry out
game plan that we saw the 49ers
Implement well I think every team
obviously goes to the strength of their
defense and conversely they go to the
strength of their offense you know if
you're Philadelphia's pass defense is
horrible but if you're not able to throw
the ball and you're a good running team
you better just do what you do well but
the notion that you have a blueprint I
I've I've seen that just way too many
times Dan in the NFL where team comes in
stops the other team whether it be
defense or offense and all of a sudden
here's a blueprint you know what the
blueprint is having Nick Bosa a
defensive end having Fred Warner as your
inside linebacker that that's a heck of
a blueprint right it's like New England
hey we've all seen that you know the
blueprint for New England was having
number 12 as your
quarterback great to talk to you have
fun this weekend and uh thanks for
joining us and to Kyle in California we
say hello to him as well you you just
made his day thank you Dan have a great
weekend thank you buddy that's babe
lenberg Cowboys radio color analyst for
27 years and a former NFL quarterback